yeah well she'll tough it out uh neil
and um there will be of course that vote
of no confidence later
today which she will survive because the
snp have the support of the greens
this report all 192 pages of it
has just been published we revealed the
key details of course last week and
it carries confirmation this morning
that in the view of the harassment
committee by majority
they believe that nicholas sturgeon
misled that committee
in her evidence about a key meeting and
therefore
misled parliament in its view it is a
potential breach of the ministerial code
but it does make the point that
the committee believes the james
hamilton report that was the one
yesterday that
uh concluded nicolas surgeon had not
breached the ministerial code
this committee is saying that the james
hamilton report is the most appropriate
place
to address the question of whether or
not the first minister has preached
the scottish ministerial code so i
suppose nicola sturgeon
who declared herself not guilty on the
back of the james hamilton report
yesterday
will point to that particular passage as
evidence that as she would have it she
is
in the clear there is much more in this
report to digest over the coming
wee while but there is criticism of
scotland's top civil servant leslie
evans for
her handling of this affair and um
you know many other matters jermaine
to the whole salmon affair which
will be articulated and full i suppose
in this parliament today and no
confidence vote
result of that 7 35 this evening but as
i say nicholas thojan
will survive that james uh for now
thanks very much indeed i will let james
uh get on with having a closer look at
that which we've published but
that which has just been published but
of course we have been uh out trying to
secure comment from
uh the lady in question the first
minister nicholas sturgeon here's what
she's been saying today
all right you know what i'm going to
leave uh
politics to others today my thoughts
today
one year on from the country going into
lockdown are with
the almost 10 000 families across the
country who've lost a loved one and to
everybody who's made
really painful sacrifices over the past
year so my priority today is to continue
to take the decisions that help get the
country through this most difficult
times do you think the hollywood inquiry
seems too part of that
excuse me
and the first ministerial car pulls away
but let's stick with the story joining
us to discuss this some more is that
myrtle fraser and he's a
scottish conservative msp and of course
member of the scottish government's
handling of harassment
harassment complaints uh committee mr
fraser good to see you this morning um
i suppose the question has to be now
that we've had the the independent
report now that we've had the
parliamentary
inquiry including it's pretty clear
nicolas sturgeon is not going anywhere
well this report by the parliamentary
committee spent
many many hours taking evidence and
looked at thousands of documents and has
come to a very
uh significant set of conclusions the
great majority which incidentally were
agreed unanimously
on a cross-party basis which points to
really significant failings
within the scottish government failings
that led to two women who made
complaints
against the former first minister alex
simon not having those complaints
properly addressed
a scottish government complaints process
that was held by the highest court in
scotland
to be unlawful on a waste of hundreds of
thousands of pounds
of taxpayers money paying alex salmon's
legal costs
and what's extraordinary about this is
that nobody has taken responsibility
nobody has lost their job and nobody has
resigned and nicolas sturgeon is head
of the scottish government today she has
to take responsibility
for these catastrophic failings under
her watch as first minister
sure i i i understand all of that but on
the central question relating to whether
or not nicolas sturgeon can continue in
post breach of the ministerial code
isn't the case that your inquiry said
the independent inquiry is best placed
to decide on that
it has decided on that it is said that
the first minister is not in breach
of the ministerial court that she did
not mislead parliament
well as our committee's view that she
did mislead the committee
and did therefore mislead parliament let
me quote you what james hamilton says
in his report at paragraph 7.11 he says
it is for the scottish parliament to
decide whether they were misled
by the first minister so this is a
committee of the parliament that has
come to a view
after a great deal of detailed
consideration of the evidence that
nicolas sturgeon did
mislead the committee and did therefore
mislead parliament
on that point mr fraser your committee
did not feel that it could put itself in
a position to decide whether or not
she had misled parliament intentionally
whether that she had been
reckless to the potential that she had
misled parliament recklessly you can
mislead parliament and not have to
resign you have to intend
to mislead parliament you have to intend
to deceive parliament and
neither your committee nor the
independent lawyer-led inquiry have been
able to conclude that
well it is the opinion of mr hamilton
that is up to the parliament to decide
whether or not the first minister misled
it now our committee's view is she did
mislead the committee in terms of what
she told us uh therefore our view is
that she should resign as a result
what is what impact has had that has all
of this had do you think from from your
perspective of course as
a scottish conservative under an snp
administration
but what is your assessment of of how
the continuing allegations
the continuing questioning of the most
senior politician in scotland what
effect that might have had
on the case for independence it
certainly seems to be reflected a little
bit at least in the polls of late
i think this whole incident has been
incredibly damaging
to the institutions of government in
scotland you know we expect politicians
to tell the truth we expect politicians
to be held to a high standard we expect
politicians
not to let down the people who work for
them we expect politicians not
to waste public money defending court
actions which are
indefensible in all these respects
nicolas sturgeon and the snp government
have let
scotland down and i'm not surprised that
we're seeing a shift in the opinion
polls now
with a slide in support for for
independence and a slide in support for
the snp
because they are seeing serious failings
in government which have been exposed
are being exposed i get that point
there are two there are two key votes
that are coming up of course the vote of
no confidence
which nicholas sturgeon will win in the
scottish parliament
and of course elections to the scottish
parliament come may which
despite all the negative press everyone
expects the snp
to do particularly well she'll win the
vote of no confidence the snp will
undoubtedly be the most successful party
in the scottish parliamentary elections
i mean the people of scotland either
through their representatives at the
scottish parliament
or through the ballot box will be
signaling to an extent
their support of nicholas sturgeon in
her position
well let's not prejudge the outcome of
the election before
a single vote is being cast the election
is still some weeks away
i think people will look at what we've
seen over the last
few days and over many weeks before that
we have a
governing party in scotland at war with
itself with the former leader of the
party the former first minister
claiming a conspiracy against them by
leading people
in the party today and taxpayers money
being wasted
and female complainants who've made
concerns raised against that former
first minister
badly let down that's no way to conduct
government and i think when people see
the detail of this report today and they
see what this committee on a cross-party
basis
making conclusions almost exclusively on
a unanimous basis
about the failings in government when
people see that they will start asking
very serious questions
as to whether nicolas sturgeon and the
snp are fit
to continue to be in government in
scotland given the very serious errors
that they've made and the amount of
public money that has been wasted